all right man if you want to say how do
I one are any of you with a good woman
like like anyone married anyone married
we're not married yet no no married okay
I just wanted to get okay how do you
find a good woman how do I find one yeah
identical one
um I think a good woman I can't I can't
throw a good woman straight away it has
to be a long course of time she needs to
be how I want when I want when I need
her to be and I won't get that from the
first look basis you know I mean so I
think at first
um a good woman to me
is a woman that has good family values
that know how to
be around their family that has a good
relationship with her dad
um submissive
um
caring nurturing
healthy
that's about it all right caring so buy
it from you uh and how do you know a
good one so right now this is what you
have to do you have to see her for three
months yeah ask her to make you a coffee
yeah
yeah that's three month things three
months
um this is for the woman you picked to
marry so like okay and you can make
edits so it's okay
um take on a coffee date for first date
okay
um date as many women as possible to
tell the difference make sure she's not
on birth control and figure out what her
relationship's like with her family and
her dad what do you agree with disagree
with them would you like to add
[Music]
like
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's certain things you'll see but
I'm saying from my experience I have
three kids in it so
I saw the biggest change when the woman
had a child okay so how long should you
see her before you marry or knock her up
whatever I don't know about Mario not
corrupt three months is a good time to
determine whether she's being genuine
because she's wearing a Moscow yeah so
you got to see her for three months in
order to date her like what's that I
mean it should be everything I don't
think you as he said you can't really
determine anyone as the true person as
they're being genuine as they say they
are for like the first three months
January if you've lived with someone
that's different if you move in with
some you can see the truth like a lot
quicker actually can I can I I'm sorry
I'm a little add sometimes when when do
you guys expect to sleep with her
it's not a problem if you sleep with a
woman the first night or you sleep with
a woman two months down the line because
man could move different man can wait
without a woman with her as soon as you
can yeah
because you couldn't you could sleep
with a woman straight away and have a
great connection and a great
relationship with her or you can a woman
can hold out for six months and whatever
and there's man out here that will sit
there for six months out all right how
long is too long I need hands okay how
long is too long no matter how good the
girl is you ain't waiting like this is
really I think three months is the
market okay okay that's why I want hands
for the men are you waiting one all
right wait wait wait wait
two weeks
three weeks
he so you're putting in three weeks it
depends on the context I mean has she
made other people wait you don't know
that yeah
I mean like how how old is she like I
mean it's just some kind of born-again
Virgin I don't know I don't know
first date like so you don't know you've
just met her off the street whatever
dating app whatever so you have to
determine all right so three weeks you
can wait you're not you're he's okay
four weeks four weeks too long for
anyone no five weeks okay two months too
long
to sleep with her the two months is the
max all right after that yeah
yeah I get bored easily so after two
months two two months yeah I'll go I'll
go with two to three months two to three
months all right so three all right so
you guys two you said I don't know but
the thing is I've done three months when
I was young maybe when I'm older now I
don't I don't know that's why I'm in but
when I had the three months
before you meet a nice woman do you
think you're you're looking for she's
the one
you have to know
uh you have to be in our life for that
whole time I understand her how old are
you again I'm 29. okay you're 29. so how
old women do you usually date around my
age so if she's not gonna build one will
you wait for a year for her
she's not a virgin but I wait for a year
if I was yeah I could do I could do it's
not likely I could do are you sleeping
with other people at the time you're
waiting yeah
yeah
I don't know if she's waiting for him
that's a good question okay okay
yeah but I'm saying it depends how much
all right
the average the out the nice I don't
know your favorite girl that you've been
on a date with let's just take her you
guys can think of whoever your favorite
X is whatever all right would you have
waited a year for her
yeah I did oh you did okay
um so you'll wait a year you'll wait two
months two months you'll wait what
when you say now you're saying favorite
yo
you know what I would wait visually I
would wait but one of the if we are
talking about favorites it didn't last
it didn't take long it was first time no
but how long would you wait for a girl
you liked that's what I'm saying I I
just used that as you know giving oh no
I can't answer that question please
answer the question you're here to
answer my questions
give me an answer please it doesn't have
to be set I would wait too much yeah two
months okay thank you thank you so much
you're like three weeks roughly a month
a month yeah so one month two months a
year we gotta yeah okay so step one
sleep with her as soon as possible
and way up to
up to one month
two a year
on the guy because what if you wait a
year and you don't like it um
I wasn't only in that one into that one
song yeah
okay well okay so don't wait now we're
going back don't wait uh I don't know
just just for him though he's waiting
yeah okay so next step okay so when
should you ask her to make you a coffee
that's what we have I'd even drink
coffee okay so what what else how else
do you evap to for a good woman
um you know what
the good woman yeah I think you need it
depends on the communication and the
conversation that you have so going
coffee is
I agree apple and the maddest thing is
the girl I'm seeing now this is the
first time I've ever gone coffee and we
had a mad conversation in Costa over
coffee and I've never done that before
which is mad but why are you telling you
well once you have a good comment
through conversation and through certain
things a man would get an idea so like
what adding on to what Rome's the same
with family values traditional maybe
even fear or God like conversations with
her you understand a lot more about it
you know I'm saying if she could can she
even compensate can we have a proper
conversation together you know what I'm
saying
okay so take on coffee date sleep with
her as soon as possible coffee day after
I'll finish waiting
oh oh so that yeah okay I know coffee
day after you finish waiting that's a
waste of time nah man you gotta go first
what okay
go on coffee date either before or after
you sleep with her
can I just say really quickly I promise
the reason why you could say that now is
because you're in a position to
be open to be receptive to her as well
you know some guys would be like what
you know like we're going clubbing or
you know it depends on the man as well
yeah 100 I'm not gonna blame on the men
but it's a two-way street a lot of
police man has so I've probably gone
through dating women yeah through this
gone through that yeah when I meet
someone I can analyze a good woman to
get what I'm saying yeah and it's it's
through action I feel like to your
question of where's all the good women
gone yeah I feel like a lot of good
women
don't have the values of back in the day
so women I don't know back in there
because I was born back in the day but I
think a lot of women don't want to show
wife credentials before they're a wife
so they will hold things back expecting
you to put a ring on their finger
because it's like oh I I couldn't do
this but I'm not gonna do these until
I'm your wife
thinking right if you're gonna cool
there's other girl out here that's going
to show me what a wife is but imagine
acting like a wife and doing full for
all different but full for all
to go and see someone else or
I'll do that the man's gone so if you so
do you want to show him do you want to
show him that you're a wife because a
man coming into is showing you already
I'm a husband promotion don't you do the
job first or do you say promote me with
no work experience
okay one second me and you are in a
relationship or we're building up a
relationship and then we go out
and then I'm and I don't know gal beat
you up for something happens right right
I'm here to protect you but I had to
stand there and just watch you when we
go home now what are you gonna say no no
one would I mean no no don't say no one
do that you can't say no one because
there's man out here that's not going to
protect you so our job is to our job's
to
protests okay forget the semantics my
job is to protect and provide for you if
I don't protect you when I'm out with
you and you're rolling out with me when
we go home what are you saying to me
as in fighting situation that's a bit no
it's not a good example okay whatever
the situation where you need protecting
and I don't protect you in that
situation what are you doing after that
situation I don't I can't answer that
question because I don't know what you
mean by protective you're deciding that
he's not the one that doesn't make it's
happened to me before it was like an
accident yeah in Costa Rica there was
like a canoeing thing and a kayak thing
and he didn't show up and I was I really
questioned my future with this guy that
for me it was done it done cool cool
yeah so if you don't show up all right
he didn't but if you don't show your
wife credentials to the man what do you
think he's gonna do the thing is there's
an extent there's a limit you can't do
everything because you don't know if
that man's serious yet you don't know
what's going on but you can't do
everything and I'm not you're not out
here
that's
that's foe like that's the thing like
you're going into something in bad faith
oh I can't do too much for him otherwise
he might not pick me up anyway yeah but
but it's like you're going into things
in fear and you don't get anything worth
having if you go into [__] scared
exactly like you can get your heart
broke like it happens scared money don't
make no money yeah but it's like you
have to in order to okay in order to to
start this whole podcast I had to invest
first but women want all the outcomes
without having to invest anything
I feel like it's a two-way thing as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible